when I look back at my childhood from
the vast age of 61 I see that the the
line from what my first impulse to the
career that I've ended up has has been
very very clear in that when I was seven
I've got photographs of making theaters
out of shoe boxes with cutouts and made
the scenery and then put cutouts from
magazines on lollipop sticks and use
those as like very crude puppets then I
made hand puppets then I got Pelham
string puppets every year for Christmas
and birthday and I had a full-sized
marionette theater my parents garage and
was in every school play that I could
possibly in and involved in this was now
a theatre theatre club that was where I
grew up so there was there's no where
that impulse came from the first place I
have no idea because I have no
theatrical roots in my family whatsoever
so when I look back on that it's you
know it's absolutely clear that's that's
what I wanted to do but because of where
I grew up it seemed as ludicrous as
saying that you wanted to be an
astronaut would you know in the land on
the moon in 1969 when I was 12 and I
said I wanted to be an actor people go
yeah you know so the fact that I then
went to drama school in University and
then became a professional actor is the
fulfillment of what I had always wanted
to do but when you're a kid I don't know
that you have such a clear idea but you
know looking back as I just said the
line is very clear I think almost every
actor I know has this experience where
it's like no is invisibly tattooed on
people's heads they go we don't want you
we're not going to give you the job
we're not gonna give you the break or
the chance and once you accept that no
is the default mode that people go into
and you get used to that you go I'm
gonna keep trying until you break
through until somebody says yes I also
had the great good fortune of having a
music
English teacher called bunny Barnes who
died 10 years ago
at the age of 89 who throughout my
childhood when my parents were I think
pretty taken aback that I wanted to
become an actor
she gave me moral support and
encouragement and having one person that
believes in you is invaluable and the
letters that we exchanged when I once I
was an adult I go back to you know
fairly frequently because her advice and
and just somebody that goes yes you can
do it is incredibly powerful when I had
completed drama school training in
University his professor gave the
end-of-year assessment of what he
thought your career prospects were as
professionally as possible and he said
you look too weird to really make it as
an actor in my opinion he said you've
shown real talent as a director and a
writer I think that is that going to be
the path of your career so because I
respected him and admired him I thought
well that is maybe what is going to
happen so when I finally got you know
the first movie role that I ever got in
1986 playing with nail in with no and I
all of his advice came to hold me in
that every single review that I remember
reading talked about the fact that I had
lantern-jawed tombstone featured cEPAL
coral bucket face you know it was
concentrating on what I looked like and
I thought oh that's exactly what the
professor told me what he got wrong
mercifully for me is that I have had and
continue to have a career as a paid
actor rather than being a director
although I have done that as well when I
got with Nolan in 1986
I'd been unemployed for nine months so
your self-esteem is absolutely
annihilated as an actor because if
you're not working then you feel like
you have no idea
so being cast to play a bitter
out-of-work actor having been embittered
and out of work for nine months was a
sort of synchronicity of life experience
and then playing this character
[Music]
certainly his this characters
self-destruct button and sense of
entitlement it's not what I feel that I
have but it's the irony of having played
an unemployed actor which has led to
almost every single job I've had since
including this Melissa McCarthy film
that's you know I mean at the moment can
you ever forgive me as a result of being
in that film 32 years ago is something
that still amuses me that's that's that
it's had that fallout effect really when
we made the film nobody had any idea
that it might be success because it had
a title that people said was
unpronounceable it had no women no car
chases Crocodile Dundee was the big hit
of 1986 while we were shooting his film
up in Cumbria and there was nobody
famous in it and they said well and
there was no plot to speak of so on
paper that the wisdom was that it would
never get released so you know I thought
what just if maybe just one or two
people see it then maybe I'll get
further employment and the other thing
that I'm very often asked is how much of
it was improvised and there was not a
single word or comma or apostrophe that
wasn't scripted by Bruce Robinson who
wrote and directed it and he was and
remains a complete stickler for that
because he said if I spent years you
know working my guts out to get the
dialogue exactly as I want them I will
not have some actor coming along and
going oh I'm just gonna make up what I'm
going to improvise so he was very very
script specific about that
I think first and foremost what draws
you to any project is the quality of the
script even though I have been hand on
heart been in spice well the movie
because my eight-year-old daughter was
absolutely obsessed that I work with
them because she could then meet them
and they were absolutely amazing and we
had a great time on it because a lot of
it was improvised
so that was hugely enjoyable for you
know to do as a job but being asked to
do something different to the thing that
you've just done is always what you hope
is going to happen so that you don't get
locked into only playing one kind of
part and essentially you know I've had a
I suppose what do you call a journeyman
actors career in that I've had some fame
and recognition but I've not had the
kind of career where some people only
get to play one kind of part and that's
what they're forced to do a night I
worked on a disastrous movie called
Hudson Hawk 30 years ago with Bruce
Willis and he said to me why are you
prepared to play people who are sexually
deviant or morally this or whatever he
said because I play heroes and I said do
you not find that limiting or dull in
any way he looked at me as the host
mentally [ __ ] and said no that's
that's what I like to play but he said
you English guys are prepared to play
people who are unsympathetic or weird or
oddball or whatever and I said but
that's what makes it interesting
otherwise you're just doing the same
thing aren't you
and he said well I earn a lot of money
doing that and I couldn't argue with
that the real person that I play called
Jack Hawking can you ever forgive me
obviously Melissa McCarthy plays Lee
Israel nobody I never met anybody that
knew him all of his friends had died of
AIDS in the mid 90s and he died of AIDS
in 1994 very little was known about Lee
Israel herself which she was very
reclusive and private writer I did have
I do have an biography that she'd
written of this American actress for
1940s core Tallulah
head and so I have on my shelf as you
know Tallulah Bankhead by Lee Israel but
because she was a biographer who's used
her talent to subsume herself so that
she wasn't at the forefront of trying to
be famous in her own right I didn't know
anything about her life and had no idea
as most people didn't seem to did the
fact that she became a literary forger
of famous dead writers work out of
economic necessity and she falls in
collusion with Jack Hawke who is an
alcoholic petty thief drug dealer who'd
been in jail for a couple of years that
I didn't know this about him because he
held up a taxi driver at knifepoint and
and he was basically he was hiv-positive
by the time they met and they fall into
this love-hate platonic relationship
because he's a gay man and she's a
lesbian writer a lesbian woman and it
goes through all the vicissitudes of
friendship in that the initial sort of
honeymoon followed by loyalty phase of
friendship is then followed by the
inevitable betrayal and then the
reconciliation just before he dies
because Leah's royal asks jack for
permission to write the story which
becomes can you ever forgive me
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]